من ملف التطورات في السودان حيث افاد
مراسله الجزيره بسماع اطلاق نار متقطع
وتحليق للطيران جنوبي مدينه ام درمان بعد
ساعات من بدء سريان اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
بين الجيش والدعم السريع هو الاول الذي
سيخضع لمراقبه وسطاء التفاوض كما شهدت
مدينه الاوبيض بولايه شمال كردفان تبادل
الاطلاق نار كثيف من الناحيه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه بالقرب من حي السكه وذكرت مصادر
محليه سماع اصوات دوي الرصاص ما ادى
لاغلاق سوق المدينه
وكان الجيش السوداني قد اعلننا في بيان عن
اشتباكات متفرقه مع قوات الدعم السريع في
اجزاء من العاصمه القوميه واشار البيان
الى ان قوات الجيش وجه الضربات لقوات
الدعم السريع في شارع الغابه بالخرطوم
وكبدتها خسائر في الاسلحه والمعدات
انضم الينا من الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره
اسامه سيد احمد اهلا بك معنا اسامه نحاول
ان نستطلع معك الاوضاع بدءا من وقف اطلاق
النار ومدى الالتزام به
تسمعني اسامه طبعا في ما يتعلق
بالتطورات الميدانيه منذ صباح اليوم هنا
في منطقه شرق شرق الخرطوم وجنوب الخرطوم
ايضا لم نرصد اي اصوات لاي شكل لاي نوع من
انواع الاسلحه سواء كانت خفيفه او ثقيله
بعد سريان الهدنه الانسانيه ووقف اطلاق
النار الذي تم الاتفاق عليه في مدينه جده
السعوديه بين الجيش السوداني واقواد الدعم
السريع هنا ان اتحدث في هذه المنطقه منطقه
جنوب الخرطوم وشرق الخرطوم ايضا ولكن خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه يعني كنا قد رصدنا تحليق
للطيران الحربي في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم
ومنطقه جنوب الجنوب ام درمان عفوا وكذلك
السماع اصوات لاس خفيفه وثقيله
تصاعدت يعني
تصاعد الدخان في منطقه وسط الخرطوم ولا
ندري ان كان هناك تفجير او شكل من اشكال
الهجوم ولكن
الدخان يتصاعد من منطقه وسط الخرطوم في
هذه في هذه اللحظات طبعا الاتفاق الذي نفذ
او بدا سريانه بالفعل
وقف اطلاق النار لمده سبعه ايام وكذلك
الهدنه الانسانيه الذي تم الاتفاق عليها
فيما يبدو انها يعني تعاني بعض
الخروقات فيما يتعلق بتنفيذها على الارض
فعليا نشاهد هنا
دخان يتصاعد وسط الخرطوم
يعني ربما يكون
هجوم او يكون شكل من اشكال الاشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع كذلك
في ان نتحدث عن عمليات عسكريه وهناك في
مدينه الاوبيض في ولايه شمال كردفان يعني
كانت هناك اطلاق نار كثيف في المدينه منذ
الصباح اليوم وهذه التطورات طبعا تاتي عقب
دخول
الاتفاق الانساني
ووقف اطلاق النار ما بين الطرفين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع طبعا هذه
التطورات الميدانيه الاخيره التي سبقت
التي اعقبت هذا الاتفاق ودخوله حيز
التنفيذ بالفعل عند التاسعه وخمس واربعين
دقيقه في مساء امس بتوقيت الخرطوم طبعا
هذه التطورات الميدانيه طبعا
توازيها معاناه كبيره فيما يتعلق بالعمليه
الانسانيه لمن بقي في المناطق او متداخله
لها في حاله انعدام
للعمليه والوضع الانساني طبعا يظل متفاقم
في ظل استمرار هذه العمليات العسكريه
ويرجو المواطنون وينتظرون انتهاء هذه
الحرب وعلى الاقل الاستفاده من الايام
السبعه التي يعني تتحدث عن اتفاق انساني
ووقف اطلاق النار لمده سبعه ايام اسامه
سيدي احمد من الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك على
كل هذه الاضاحات